bonsoir alexis poulain merci d'être avec
nous ce soir sur arte france donc la
défenseure des lois des droits à semer
le trouble avec une proposition
d'expérimentation de zone sans contrôle
d'identité oui alors cette proposition
comme vous venez de le dire a suscité un
vif débat a été très mal reçue par les
syndicats de policiers qui eux ont parlé
de fan zone pour les délinquants qui ont
rappelé aussi la continuité de la loi et
du droit qui doit être la même pour tous
et partout sur le territoire
donc pourquoi vouloir à certains
endroits à voir des zones
d'expérimentation de nos contrôles
d'identité elle est revenu bien sûr elle
a levé l'ambiguïté
il y avait également stanislas guérini
un responsable du parti la république en
marche qui dit que c'était un recul
phénoménal de la république mais il faut
rappeler d'où vient cette idée
finalement elle vient de l'interview
qu'avait donnée macro président de la
république fondateur du parti la
république en marche à brut lorsqu'il
disait qu effectivement il y avait des
délits de contrôle au faciès et qu'il
fallait y remédier et que donc il allait
ouvrir une plateforme pour dénoncer les
discriminations c'est ce qui a été fait
par querrey dont la défenseur des droits
c'était le 12 février cette plateforme a
été ouverte va s'ensuivre une
consultation de deux semaines sur les
discriminations et donc quand on remet
dans le contexte on comprend pourquoi
claire hédon a proposé cette idée pour
aller dans le sens finalement du
président de la république c'est là
toute la magie du en même temps d'un
côté mais elle macron dit quelque chose
de l'autre
le gouvernement veut en faire une autre
et la république en marche ne s'y
retrouve plus donc voilà où on en est et
puis il ya la réalité sur le terrain
pour les policiers qui reste quand même
critique avec ses poulains une polémique
qui enfle un toujours avec autant de
violence dans certains quartiers en
direction des forces de l'ordre on l'a
vu notamment à poissy 1 ces derniers
jours oui c'est ce qui fait en fait que
l'annoncé est très mal tombé a été très
mal reçue par les policiers les
syndicats de policiers c'est qu'on a vu
cette vidéo de lynchage de policiers par
des jeunes qui au son de tuer les tuer
les avait pris en embuscade
une patrouille de police et c'est vrai
que c'est quelque chose qui se répète
qu'on connaît les pompiers les policiers
qui sont appelés pour intervenir dans
des quartiers et qui sont en fait pris
au piège dans des guets-apens
les jeunes des quartiers qui sont là
pour rétorquer pour casser du flic d'une
certaine façon et c'est inacceptable
évidemment le maire de poissy car le
livre lui disais que c'est très
regrettable c'est scandaleux c'est
inacceptable malheureusement c'est quasi
quotidiens ces scènes là on les a trop
souvent on a même vu des concours sur
les réseaux sociaux de quartier à
quartier qui filmait les fameux
guets-apens et qui comme ça essayez de
voir qui était le plus violent avec avec
les policiers gérald darmanin a rappelé
que s'attaquer aux policiers s'est
attaqué à la république il a voulu bien
sûr revenir dans le débat politique et
c'est bien toute la sphère en fait ce
débat devient extrêmement politique
puisque on est en train d'entrer dans
des phases de d'élections élections des
régionales et puis la présidentielle
bien sûr qu'ils arrivent en 2022 donc le
débat revient le débat sécuritaire sur
le devant de la scène mais alors
justement vous parlez du débat et de la
surenchère sécuritaire est ce qu'il y à
une surenchère sécuritaire pour la
république en marche a clairement très
clairement
d'ailleurs c'est gérald darmanin qui est
en charge de l' aile sécuritaire pour
aller draguer finalement l'électorat de
marine le pen et du rassemblement
national lui-même a d'ailleurs annoncé
nous voulons montrer qu'il ya une
alternative à marine le pen puisqu'en
fait pour lui si marine le pen exister
parce qu'il ya des problèmes donc elle
n'a aucun intérêt à résoudre les
problèmes donc lui gérald darmanin que
fait-il eh bien ils créent davantage de
problèmes finalement en essayant de
faire croire à l'électorat du
rassemblement national que la république
en marche va être le parti qui va
répondre à leurs attentes et il n'y a
pas que lui d'ailleurs qui drague
l'électorat du front national jean
michel blanquer ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui a eu des sorties
abracadabrantesque sur les enfants qui
refusait de s'asseoir sur des chaises
rouges parce que ce serait la couleur du
diable ou bien des hangars où l'islam
aurait était et inculquer aux enfants
lors des des enfants qui ne sont pas à
l'école inquiet avec l'enseignement à la
maison vous avez également marc et le
chat pas qui fait la chasse aux petites
filles qui refusent d'aller à la piscine
et qui appelle ça du séparatisme
et frédéric vidal dernière en date
ministre de la recherche qui elle plutôt
que de s'occuper du sort des étudiants
qui tombent dans la précarité et bien a
préféré mettre en place une commission
d' enquête sur l'islamo gauchisme dans
les facultés françaises
elle a reçu une fin de non recevoir de
la part de la conférence des présidents
d'université qui ont dit que c'était un
débat stérile non avenue et qu'il
fallait arrêter là et c'est vrai que
dans la surenchère sécuritaire dans
l'assurance air islamophobe d'une
certaine façon xénophobe on va dire il
est là une course à l'échalote de la
part de la république en marche qui
voudrait se présenter finalement comme
le parti de l'extrême droite efficace
qui fonctionne parce qu'on pouvoir et
enlever tous les électeurs finalement de
marine le pen pour 2022 et en même temps
se positionner face à une gauche
critique pour les taxes et e d'islamo
gauchistes c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement dangereuse c'est une
mécanique qu'on connaît qui n'a jamais
fonctionné d'ailleurs puisqu'il ne fait
que renforcer les idées du rassemblement
national plutôt que ceux qui essayent de
siphonner l'électorat de marine le pen
donc attention à ce choix stratégique
qui semble être une impasse mais
malheureusement rien n'est fait pour
siffler la fin de la récréation est
d'ailleurs la loi séparatisme et des
valeurs de la république vient d'être
votée aujourd'hui à la majorité à
l'assemblée nationale donc le débat
risque d'être encore longtemps sur la
table parce qu'à chaque élection
présidentielle c'est d'abord la sécurité
qui a été un des étendards pour d'une
certaine façon montrer les camps
politiques et le en même temps
malheureusement ne marche pas dans ce
cas là et ça pourrait être la fin de la
république en marche avec beaucoup
j'imagine de députés de la majorité qui
ne se retrouveront pas dans ce virage à
l'extrême droite deux du parti
présidentiel
merci alexis poulain pour vous précisez
vos précisions je rappelle que vous êtes
éditorialistes